una impresionante procesión de varios
cientos de metros para marcar una fecha
simbólica el cuadragésimo día tras la
muerte de maxa Mini sinónimo del fin del
periodo de luto tradicional en Irán la
multitud se dirige al cementerio de la
ciudad natal de la joven en el kurdistán
iraní en los videos publicados en las
redes sociales cientos de personas
corean consignas en farcy contra el
líder supremo de la nación este año es
el año de la sangre alija minei será
derrocado sin embargo el día anterior
las fuerzas de seguridad se desplegaron
en la ciudad de origen de amini para
impedir las concentraciones en este
último día de luto las autoridades
iraníes también actuaron en Terán con la
llegada de la policía antidisturbios
maxa mini de 22 años había sido detenida
por la policía de la moral por llevar
supuestamente al jillab mal ajustado en
la cabeza como marca el estricto código
de vestimenta de la República islámica
murió tres días después en el hospital
su muerte provocó una gran conmoción en
Irán y en todo el mundo a esto le sigue
un movimiento de protestas sin
precedentes en tres años las jóvenes
quemaron sus velos y desafiaron a las
fuerzas de seguridad el poder judicial
iraní anunció el miércoles que había
acusado a más de 300 personas lo que
eleva el número oficial de cargos a más
de mil desde que iniciaron las protestas